the Church of the Nativity in Bethlehem
visitors from around the world flock
here every Christmas season this year
the old church has been given a new look
these tops conceal three years of
intense labor and a real treasure
mosaics from the 12th century restored
to multicolored brilliance
high above laferrari
duvet being able to work here where it
all began from where the years are
counted where our civilization was born
including my own mode of living our
religion is unbelievable it is
magnificent Italian experts have
restored the weathered mosaics with
painstaking precision for centuries
water leaked through the church roof
damaging the artwork and only makeshift
solutions buckets to catching the
dripping rain water until the Christian
community was able to agree on urgently
needed renovations today the roof no
longer leaks the 600 year old wooden
beams have been reinforced and the
mosaics have been revealed once again
pilgrims from all over the world have
waited centuries to see those beautiful
mosaics and here they are coming alive
again the 12th century angel mosaics
have also been brought back to life this
piece dating back to the Crusades was
hidden for centuries only recently
rediscovered 900 years ago artists
harness light using a special technique
every single mosaic stone is set at a
certain angle to best reflect the
sunlight this angels gaze falls on the
Jesus grotto it points the way for
earthbound pilgrims according to the
Bible Jesus is supposed to have been
born here
it's history to live in history and I
was blessed
I was blessed being here connecting to
talk to my Lord on my personal Savior
Jesus very beautiful very moving very
touching so honored to be here the
renovation is meant to preserve and
protect the church for future
generations especially in this difficult
time where we see churches destroyed all
over the Middle East we are very proud
as Palestinians despite all the
difficulties that we are we have been
able to implement this project we
consider this church as part of our
heritage national heritage as Christians
as Muslims as Palestinians and in the
Palestinian West Bank the people of
Bethlehem also say that especially now
it's important that good news be
conveyed to the rest of the world from
the Church of the Nativity